Iran's Revolutionary Guards since the
country is now able to quote
monitor the world from space after
successfully launching its first
military satellite into orbit
the US has accused Iran in the past of
using its space program as a cover for
missile development allegations iran
denies president donald trump in
washington while not addressing the
launch directly did tweet a warning
about iran harrassing american ships at
sea is what the head of the
Revolutionary Guard said about the
launch well connected therefore you more
it is a necessity for such powerful
defense forces like the Revolutionary
Guards to have access to advanced
capabilities today the powerful armies
of the world have no comprehensive
defense plan if they don't have a place
in space today we can monitor the world
from space and it means boosting
strategic data for the IRGC putting the
satellite into orbit gives us a
technological advantage and is also a
powerful asset in the intelligence war
well they're on has spent a decade
trying to improve its rocket technology
it fired its first successful satellite
into orbit in 2009 but in recent months
it's had several failed launches the
latest coming in February when Iran
failed to put its a for one
communication satellite into orbit and
last year it had three failures
including a rocket explosion in August
the United States called those actions
provocative however Iran has maintained
that its satellite program did not have
a military component a White House
correspondent Kimberly halket is
monitoring reaction for us out of
Washington this hour but first live
Tuesday in Basra v who joins us from
Tehran says Ain this satellite what can
it do well what we know is what we've
heard from the military really this came
as a surprise not just to the rest of
the world but to Iranians as well they
awoke to what is effectively the news of
a successful secret operation carried
out by the Islamic Revolutionary Guard
Corps from a desert location in the
central desert area of Iran they heard
that this morning that this rocket was
launched into space the satellite names
mirror for light is now 425 kilometers
above us orbiting Earth and we heard it
straight from
the head of the IRGC himself this is for
military purposes and is likely to be
used for intelligence gathering for
military reconnaissance for navigation
and movements of military assets on the
ground all the things that leaders need
to do to support their assets on earth
from an eye on the sky in space so any
questions there may have been about
whether or not this satellite had
military capability or not the head of
the IRGC as well as the head of the
aerospace division has made clear that
these are advances in military
technology and will be used for military
purposes
Zain thanks very much let's go to
kimberly halket our White House
correspondent Kimberly good afternoon
good morning so this must be peaking
interest and raising eyebrows at the
State Department and also the building
behind you yes no official reaction from
the State Department just yet but we can
tell you of course you've already
reported the u.s. president's tweet this
of course is following the reports of
the launch of that satellite and then
sort of a warning by the US President to
Iran earlier this month where he had
said that he thought that Iran was
trying to plan a sneak attack as he
called it against US troops her assets
and he warned that there would be a
heavy price paid if that happens now
the u.s. sees the launch of this
satellite as an advancement of its
missile program and we know that the
tensions between these two sides have
been ratcheting up for months even as
the president had said that he had
restored deterrence with following the
killing the drone killing of general
Soleimani now the u.s. in recent weeks
has accused Iran of harassing the US
ships Navy ships in the Persian Gulf
they were conducting a drill outside of
Kuwait and they said that Iran's fast
boats as they're called pointed a
machine gun at one point and were
brushing up very close against the
United States ships what this is this
country the United States grappling with
dealing with the corona virus pandemic
of course there's been widespread
reporting of the USS Roosevelt of course
that's off of Guam that has been hit
with an outbreak
coronavirus on that ship the question
becomes in the United States whether or
not Iran is seizing this looking upon
the u.s. as having a bit of a
vulnerability right now it shows you
even the midst of this pandemic these
military rivalries continue